foreign
For You Joe
I mean I think we'll see
do you think though that we're let like
we're
heading more towards like we're not
going to need any muscle we're not going
to need any I think so like when you see
aliens like I remember one time we
talked about aliens and
and uh
they're I somehow I think aliens are
just people that just came back here to
it's just us it could be because it's
the heads are big the bodies are nothing
they're just whittled away to nothing
we've talked about this before if you go
back and look at primitive man they had
all these muscles and they had smaller
brains and then as people have become
more and more intelligent their bodies
are not necessary anymore in terms of
like the ability to move things around
and our heads have gotten bigger so if
you look at Bill Gates right he's
another example he's got like this body
that's basically like a water balloon
like there's no density you could stab
him with your finger you could just [ __ ]
you you could probably kill him with a
finger if you really want if you really
doubled up two fingers and taped them I
am very confident I could kill him with
two fingers you could at least make his
heart skip I just had time just remix
him to death
I think I could kill him with a thumb
100 yeah but I really think I can kill
him with two fingers because the thumb
I'm most confident jabbing something
with a thumb yeah and your thumb is more
of a base it's like it's going to put
the pressure wider two fingers is harder
but I think if I taped them up I think I
can [ __ ] them up with two fingers if you
took his [ __ ] pulse hard enough you
could put him down yes